when you drop a cell phone into water
water gets into the device very quickly
and causes corrosion damage through
alexa chemical migration often it can be
catastrophic failure when you dump phone
into water and so there is no way of
recovering it we have a technology which
is another coating technology which
provides a protective layer to the
inside and outside of electronic devices
massively improving its reliability to
water damage reproach so the backgrounds
the company is actually in military
technology to provide coatings to
military clothing work to prevent the
soldier from chemical attack like nerve
agents but also environmental threats
we've done over 50 million electronic
devices from Bluetooth headsets hearing
aids tablets and mobile phones the b2 I
technology works the molecular scale
under vacuum so what this allows is the
chemical to penetrate very freely into
the 3d structure and provides a covalent
bond which is a permanent attachment of
our coating technology throughout the
entire device there are other
smartphones out there today that's
advertised waterproof protection like
Sony phone for example what they're
doing is they're using a physical
barrier using gaskets and o-ring seals
and the drawback with the mechanical
seals is when that becomes compromised
as soon as water gets inside
catastrophic failure when you throw a
device that's been closed with our
technology into water the water still
gets into the device so it's not a
physical barrier preventing water access
but because of the technology in there
it repels it very well increased
reliability for mobile phones and
electronic devices is not a cloud it's
an absolute
the operators really need this they're
signing people up along the contracts
every time the customer comes back with
a failed device they either risk
customer churn or the active variety
replacing handset